a special thank you to Garrett
Vandenberg and Matthew Wyden for helping
me not only frame this conversation but
come up with specific questions to pose
to both Ian and John a reference to
their Channel slash podcast is in the
description and I recommend you check it
out they've interviewed both John
vervaki as well as myself also a special
thank you to sicktanic K official that
is at satanic k for the audio processing
of Ian's vocals we unfortunately had
some audio issues with Ian's microphone
and I wasn't able to fix it however this
person came through on Twitter and
helped me voluntarily even mcgilchrist
is a psychiatrist a writer and a former
Oxford literary scholar who came to
prominence with his work the master and
his Emissary subtitled The Divided brain
and the making of the Western World
we've spoken last year regarding the
very topic and the link is in the
description his new book the matter with
things our brains our delusions and the
unmaking of the world and the links to
both books are in the description John
vervaki is a professor of cognitive
science at the University of Toronto my
former home who's one of the few
Scholars taking an extensive and
meticulous cognitive scientific approach
to wisdom Buddhism and Consciousness
John and I have also spoken several
times on this podcast and you can see
the thumbnails here and the links to
each will be in the description as well
it's that latter topic Consciousness
that in more ways than one binds us here
today as usual click on the timestamp in
the description to skip this intro my
name is Kurt J mungle I'm a torontonian
filmmaker with a background in
mathematical physics and this channel is
dedicated to the explication of the
variegated terrain of theories of
everything that is primarily from a
theoretical physics perspective so for
example Grand unification and quantum
gravity but as well as understanding the
role Consciousness has to play to the
fundamental laws provided these laws
exist at all in a form knowable to us
two quick announcements firstly there's
a physics and Consciousness contest on
this channel the link to which will be
in the description as well as the
thumbnail is over here essentially it's
the physics version of the three blue
one brown math contest except hours for
physics and Consciousness as well if you
have an idea for some explainer of an
advanced physics or Consciousness
concept then think about creating a
video for this and submitting as you
have the chance to win one thousand
dollars brilliances come in to give five
thousand among the top five so that's
one thousand for each the second
announcement is that there's a new
theoriesofeverything.org website this is
a website where you can support toe
slash Curt which is me instead of on
patreon because patreon takes a huge cut
as well as PayPal takes a cut there's
many different places that take their
share and as a Creator you don't have
control over your donations so for
instance patreon may decide to shut you
down for whatever reason they like there
are also a variety of benefits that come
with being a member on the toe website
for instance you get an ad free version
of the shows that are coming out an
audio ad-free version that is to say you
get a private link to the RSS feed to
download the audio versions and they
come out about 12 to 48 Hours sometimes
even one week prior to you seeing them
here on YouTube Just so you know the way
that it works is that if finished
editing and then I have to do another
run through and go through timestamps
and catalog references and so on that
takes time and what it means is that I
put it out on YouTube and then I have a
lag so that I can build up some hype and
some audience prior to the premiere but
then that means that I've actually
finished the episode a couple days
before so what I'll do is I'll upload
simultaneously for the members an audio
version ads free and then later it
premieres on YouTube for you as the
YouTube audience nothing changes this is
the way I've always done it it's just
that I have here an audio version for a
little while prior which I'm going to
release to the toe members as a thank
you and it's going to be ads free so
that's one of the benefits from this
point forward there may be mid-rolls
that is ads in the middle of a podcast
and that's just part and parcel of the
total members of the tow audience you
are sponsoring toe and then the sponsor
is also sponsored toe so thank you for
your support those won't be there in the
audio ads free version for the toll
members second benefit is that you get
discounts to any Live Events when we do
have have them for instance I'd like to
do Carl friston in London live in front
of an audience same with E mcgilchrist
and John vervaki at some point another
benefit is that there will be exclusive
merch offered to the tone members
another benefit is that there's a number
to text me again if that's what you're
into we're testing this out for about a
month and yes this is something where I
am texting you back to your phone
throughout much of this you can see that
the artwork here is exquisite on the
website and that's because it's been
done by Boris Martinez Costello a link
to his Instagram is in the description
as well thank you Boris thank you so
much as for today's sponsor it's
brilliant brilliant.org now Brilliance
has been with toe since near the
beginning I recommend you check out
brilliant.org toe if you're interested
in learning math and physics and science
so brilliant is a place that you go to
learn about stem subjects in an
interactive manner they have these
bite-sized courses it's extremely easy
you may think that special relativity is
beyond you no it's not it's something
that someone can understand in
elementary school the way that brilliant
breaks down these extremely ordinarily
extremely advanced concepts is
Elementary at some point I'll be doing
an introduction to information theory in
particular there's David Deutsch and
Chiara marleto's Constructor Theory and
because I'd like to learn that I decided
let me brush up on the fundamentals of
information Theory and I took Brilliance
course just to do so over this winter
break visit brilliant.org toe that's toe
to get 20 off the annual subscription I
recommend that you don't stop before
four lessons just keep going until you
hit four and you'll be greatly surprised
at the ease at which you can now
comprehend subjects you previously had a
difficult time grocking okay thank you
and enjoy today's episode we'll start
this by asking each of you what is the
meaning crisis and what are its causes
and we'll start with Ian if you don't
mind well
what I understand by it is is the fact
that people have
lost any sense that things really speak
to them from somewhere beyond their own
what they've made up in their own minds
the the experience of something
um great possibly Transcendent certainly
of existential importance is harder now
because we live in a world of reductive
materialism in which everything is
supposed to be explained as the dead
movements of mechanical pieces
um
I I think this is not only incredibly
unhealthy and causes mental illness
which is not just my opinion but the
statistics speak for themselves
but is
a huge mistake in its conception because
I don't believe that meaning is
something we make up I believe it's
something we find and we have to put our
way ourselves in the way of finding it
and that would mean putting a certain
degree of vulnerability of opening
oneself to something in case one finds
there's something there and if one
doesn't open oneself through it one
won't find that at all I think it
applies to
spiritual life to religion in as much as
that is part of it of many people and it
also applies to experiences of Art and
the experiences of one another and what
it is to be a human being we've degraded
ourselves and then find ourselves in a
nihilistic
Universe where nothing makes sense and
nothing has meaning and that's a very
dangerous place to be for a number of
reasons for the course of civilization
and also for each of us as individuals
so yes it's a very important element in
the position we find ourselves in as you
know one of the things I believe has
happened is that gradually over the
course of recent western civilization
and particularly after the enlightenment
we
we overreached ourselves we we were not
content with the idea that
um thinking rationally helped banish
many unnecessary woes and mistakes and
and so on but that we actually could
understand everything and wonder if you
think you can understand everything your
chances of understanding anything
are remote
and this has been taken to hubristic
extremes during uh our lifetimes
and I associate this with the rise of a
certain way of thinking about the world
that I believe is the way in which the
left hemisphere operates it it has
evolved the way it has because it helps
us grab stuff and get stuff but it has
outsourced the business of meaning and
understanding to the right hemisphere
or to put it another way the right
hemisphere is Outsource grabbing and
getting stuff to the left hemisphere and
remained able to understand
and that would bring a different
relationship between ourselves and the
world indeed I think this idea of
relationship and encounters with reality
is a very important one which no doubt
will come back to it I argue in my
latest book the matter with things has
in fact relations of what everything is
built out of and that relations are even
prior to relata so that would be my
first
um my first attempt to give some idea of
what I think about that huge question
well
um and I suppose that's one of the
reasons why we're talking my answer is
going to be uh I find at least in my
mind by conversion with Buddy and said
um so but I'll start from a different
place but I think I'll end up in the
same or very close to where he ended up
um
I think the very processes that make us
intelligently adaptive make us
parentally susceptible to self-deceptive
self-destructive Behavior
um and that the cross time and culture
people have come up with complex systems
because this is a very complex system
and colleges of practices I call them
for intervening and ameliorating that
self-deceptive self-destructive behavior
and also enhancing the sense of
connectedness
um that is being undermined by the self
accepted self-destructive Behavior
that's to oneself to other people to the
world and when you take a look at that
sense of connectedness it overlaps very
much with what's called meaning in life
and and as Ian said we want to feel that
we are connected to something that has a
value and a reality other than our own
egocentric preferences and existence
all right so I'll often ask people what
do you mean by meaning in life and I'll
say well tell me what you would want to
continue existing even if you weren't
here and they'll tell me and I'll tell
and they'll say that's what matters to
you that's what you want that's what you
want to be connected to beyond your
egocentric preferences and your
egocentric existence
I think the capacity to ameliorate that
self-deceptive self-destructive
foolishness and to enhance the sense of
connectedness is what people what
cultures have called wisdom and I think
what we're facing today is a two-pronged
problem
um people don't know where to go for
wisdom they overwhelmingly know where to
go for information but like T.S Eliot
said we have lost the wisdom and the
knowledge and the knowledge and the
information so they precisely lack the
discernment as to what they should pay
attention to what they should take
seriously what really matters so they're
overwhelmed with information what counts
as knowledge is now significantly in
question in our culture and of course
when I ask people where they go for
wisdom I either get a deafening silence
or I get some autodidactic religion of
me that the person gives me typically
um
and so
um the fastest growing group in our
culture are the nuns n-o-n-e-s they have
no official religious affiliation that
does not mean they are overwhelmingly
atheist they are by and large they
describe themselves by this phrase that
is very popular uh to exactly agree to
which I find it vapid if they're
spiritual but not religious and it's
very hard to determine what that
actually means other than they have some
intuitive sense that they should be
seeking wisdom they should be seeking
connectedness but they distrust any of
the institutionalized sources the
problem is the the what was supposed to
offer
you'll so religions have been the home
for these ecologies of practices and the
enlightenment offered to free us from
the tyranny of religion and give us an
alternative home
and it gave us
gave us the scientific worldview a
scientific worldview which explains
everything except how we generate
science and the meaning that makes truth
possible and how science itself could
possibly exist as a real entity within
the ontology of that world of you and so
we and our science actually have no
proper home in that worldview and so the
science can't provide the home for the
Ecology of practices the religions are
are now largely regarded as obsolete or
irrelevant uh for a homing the Ecology
of practices and so the perennial
problems now go largely uh unabated or
ameliorated at Best by autodidactic
systems that have a strong proclivity
for enhancing personal bias or group
Echo chambering and of course social
media has just exacerbated uh both of
these Tendencies uh tremendously
and so we starve for meaning
uh in the midst of a wisdom famine we
can't ignore a scientific worldview
but that worldview does not properly
Place us and what it does is it gives a
tremendous emphasis on propositional
knowing at the expense of all the
non-propositional kinds of knowing
procedural perspectival and
participatory so we live in a
propositional tyranny that prevents us
from accessing those ways of knowing
that would are properly the most
powerful Vehicles by which we can
cultivate wisdom and a sense of
connectedness and I think that is the
meaning crisis and that is the situation
they're in and it's getting worse and
worse
um people experience it as a kind of
domicide a loss of home even though they
have shelter
and kobit made it much much worse and we
are seeing the mental health tsunami and
the political ramifications of the
acceleration of the meeting crisis right
now
that would be my take on it and one more
thing
because it's conversion with what Ian
said
we've lost alethea we've lost the sense
of Truth as what I call transjectivity
the deeper thing that binds subjectivity
and objectivity together the thing that
is being given prominence by four
e-cognitive science and meaning is such
a real transgender relation it's not a
it's not arbitrarily subjective it's not
merely objectively measurable it is a
proper real relation that's why I use
the term connectedness
that's
um that's what I would say there
Ian is there anything there that you
would like to respond to
I mean I I would you know brutally
accept what what um Jonah said I mean
he's he's um put really the same points
I was trying to make but just in
slightly different way with perhaps from
a different perspective
um I think we both see the importance of
something
that calls to us we can't we feel
ourselves attracted towards something
um and we've lost the confidence to go
there because
um technology and information have
substituted for deep knowledge and
wisdom which is really what what John
was saying
um and I think the dangers
in
I mean the technology problem is the
genius out of the box and it can't be
put back in but one of the difficulties
about it is all it does it doesn't
answer any questions of course all it
does is enlarge our powers to alter
things
and that's only as good as our wisdom
about what needs old thinking in what
way into what end and I don't believe we
have that wisdom at all we have more
power than we've ever had
in the history of humanity and the least
wisdom we've ever had I believe
and I think that this what um John was
calling the the rise of propositional
knowledge is very important when it
comes to look at things like belief in
the nature of
God or the world because I think they
are dispositional forms of knowing not
propositional forms of knowing and
unfortunately in recent history they've
been presented to us as propositions
that we either are sent to or fail to
Ascent to whereas in fact it's a matter
of how we attend to the world because
attention is absolutely at the root of
all of this problem we see
coffee helps me work it helps me fast
from carbs it's become one of the best
parts of my day consistently that's why
I'm delighted that we're collaborating
with Trade coffee they partner with top
independent Roasters to Freshly roast
and send the finest coffee in the
country directly to your home on your
preferred schedule this matters to me as
I work from home their team of experts
do all the work testing hundreds of
disparate coffees to land on a final
curated collection of 450 exceptional
coffees I chose these three and the team
at Trade coffee worked to create a
special lineup for theories of
everything for the tow audience based on
some questions they asked me such as how
much caffeine do I enjoy and what's the
bitterness ratio Etc you can get that
line up or if that's not let's say your
cup of coffee then you can take your own
quiz on their website to find a set that
matches your specific profile if you'd
like to support small businesses and
Brew the best cup of coffee you've ever
made at home then it's time to try Trade
coffee right now trade is offering our
listener is thirty dollars off your
first order plus free shipping at
drinktrade.com everything that's
drinktrade.com everything for thirty
dollars off
do you use the word rationality and
belief differently than John
um I don't know
I have no idea whether we do or not I
mean I tend to make a distinction which
is not one that's hard and fast in the
English language but is one I make for
the purposes of being clear about what
I'm talking about or clearer and that is
to make a distinction between
rationality and reason the rationality
is a more technical thing but reason is
the whole of one's ability to understand
the world bringing together everything
one has learned from experience one's
ability to yes reason using logic one's
ability to attend to one's intuitions
it's the power that a good judge in the
old days a wise judge as we would have
thought of him usually would have been a
him uh brought to bear on a human
situation so that's rationality I think
it's terribly important I think in our I
don't want to knock it at all it's just
that it's a certain very diminished form
of it I.E the most mechanical
rationalizations has taken over from
that deep reason that deep wisdom which
which was much admired in the
Renaissance was thought to be the the
sign of a fully educated and and
well-read person
so um I I think reasons in fact in
danger in our time and also neither do I
have anything to say against science
science is hugely important and I'm very
worried by the attacks on science for
purely political reasons science is once
we lose our anchors in reason and
science we're totally lost but also if
we only have reason and science we're
lost they need to be mixed with properly
what we can learn from intuition and
Imagination
so um uh I tend to use the word belief
to me in the assertion of a proposition
but I acknowledge it has an older
meaning a Laban which is thinking to
give your heart to exactly and uh but
I've given up uh the Battle of trying to
get people to use beliefs to mean that
uh so I'll say you could keep it for the
assertion of propositions I want to talk
about something else that the Laban used
to uh point to
um
I use I think I use rationality the way
uh Ian uses reason and I'll give you my
reasons which is I go back to the uh the
word that translated logos and when I
talk about rationality I'm talking about
what the ancient Greeks meant by logos
which is a much more comprehensive uh
you know the the self-organizing of
intelligibility such that the world can
be real to us I think that's sort of the
best understanding and the lat for that
was ratio which means a proper
proportioning and if you take a look at
like if for example the used in the
stoics OR in Plato it means the proper
proportioning is Ian said of attention
it means the proper proportioning uh uh
of your of your character traits uh
think about Aristotle's gold and me you
want to get the proper proportion
between uh being cowardly and being full
hearty so ratio is that much so ratio is
the proper proportioning of your
Consciousness your cognition and the
character and your character such that
virtue and virtue curiosity are possible
that's and I think that's the ancient
meaning of ratio and that's why I use
rationality I reserve reason for the act
of The Liberation uh but nothing much
hangs on this distinction I think Ian
and I are both pointing to something
similar which is I talked about the
truncation and the reduction of
rationality to logicality and
computation since the Advent of the
Enlightenment and we have lost all those
other aspects of
um you know of rationality the proper
proportioning like I say of attention of
consciousness of character that is
needed for virtue and I take virtue to
not mean uh acting according to a moral
rule like caught might but in the
ancient sense of being deeply connected
to what is most real
so I think the person for example who
demonstrates courage is able to see
through the distractions and distortions
of fear and connect to not just seeing
but a properly connect to what is most
real and what most matters in a
situation and therefore has the
affordance to act best in that situation
that's what I mean by a virtue
connecting us to reality so rat for me
rationality is exactly that capacity
it's interesting that the word virtual
now means precisely
um not being real in the sense well
that's that yeah and that's interesting
I mean there is a connection because
virtual have having the potential and
the potential impossibility
um I'm aware of that
um no I was just I don't think we really
disagreeing here I think it's just a
matter of which words we choose to use
sure yeah yeah I I like it uh because I
I talk about ratio religio uh the proper
proportioning of how we are bound to
things how we are connected to things
and in that sense the distinction
between what we've caught what we have
since the enlightenment called
rationality and what we used to call
religion is is diminished uh because of
religion is about again you know
appropriately binding ourselves religio
to what is most real the sacred then
ratio religio and religion are no longer
oppositional they have the potential to
enter into real discourse with each
other which I think is part of what is
needed right now and I think I hear you
saying that too I he I think you I hear
you saying I agree with you I'm a
scientist I love science and I think
people who don't practice science should
not uh recommend its eradication uh I I
think that that is a ridiculous proposal
it's even contradictory to their own
claim that you have to have a lived
experience of something in order to
really understand it so I agree with you
that that proposal is ridiculous but I
think take the the enlightenment
proposal that everything that people
were trying to Encompass what what in
what was broadly called religion which
includes a lot of what we now pulled out
is Art and ritual and ceremony that that
was also part of ratio religio that was
way in which we properly educated
especially the non-propositional aspects
of knowing uh that are are vital for the
cultivation of virtue and a sense of
meaning
um so I agree with you there too and I
hear you saying we should get those two
at least it seems to me like you would
agree with the proposal that we should
find a way to get them talking to each
other again past the division uh that
separated them in the enlightenment
yes certainly in um
in the the new book
um of mine which came out last year the
math I have it I have it by the way Ian
I haven't read it but I do have it so I
keep looking at it
I don't know I mean for that will be in
the description how you'll find the time
to read it I don't know but in this part
two of that I specifically look at the
various ways in which we can come to
something we could call truth about the
world and in in brief I did I conclude
that we need each of science reason
intuition and Imagination not just one
or two of these and if possible in most
situations we should try to bring as
many of these as possible to bear
however appropriate to whatever it is
we're looking at I don't think this is
what we're currently doing there's a
sort of naive war between scientism
people who've never really thought very
much but just imagine that whatever it
as they've fallen into believing about a
Mechanical Universe must be right
we've got a war on between them and and
other people who reject science and
reject reason and I I don't wish to
encourage either party
at most those yeah I agree and I noticed
in the second book because I have I I
didn't just put it on the Shelf I have
looked at it but it is yeah it's like I
gotta say this I didn't I this was a
thunderbolt summer for me I was
traveling so much and talking in so many
places but but you also I did note in a
second you also talked about the sacred
and recovering uh the sacred and the
second part of the book as well so
that's why I was supposing that that
whatever I'll propose to you that
whatever deficits and they're there they
are many there were there are reasons
behind the enlightenment critique but
whatever deficits there are in religion
it was an attempt to properly Orient
people towards the sacred when it was
functioning well yes undoubtedly yes yes
and actually just to clarify for for
viewers what um what John has just
referred to is is not the part two that
I was talking about is part three which
confusingly is volume two oh okay sorry
and the difference is that part two is
epistemology and part three is
metaphysics so I'm looking at what what
is
time motion space matter Consciousness
what are values what his purpose what is
the meaning of the feeling we have the
sense of the Sacred and so on so that's
a
[Music]
but anyway there we are
I'd like to talk to you about that but
first I do want to talk to you about the
previous thing you said because some of
my most recent work has been around
something that overlaps with that uh I
mean I've published on Flow and
intuition and we could we could perhaps
talk about that uh but I've been doing
recent work
um I gave it invited talk at uh invited
lecture at Cambridge about the imaginal
um and its relationship to rationality
um what I mean by rationality and
um and you know I'm filming my next
series after Socrates and there's a
whole section where I where I'm talking
about the how the neoplatonists try to
integrate the imaginal back into sort of
the depths of philosophy so I don't know
if you're aware of the distinction that
core band makes between the imaginary
and the imaginal
um would it be worthwhile for me to say
what that is
I've got an idea but I could be wrong so
if you like to unpack what you mean
there sure sure
um and then and I'll ground it in a
concrete um thing
um and then I'll try and show how just
one quick point about how you could not
you know not exhausted but exemplary of
how you could see how it functions
necessarily within what I'm calling
rationality so probably I made a
distinction but the imaginaries when you
picture things in your head and you're
and it's not for the sake of perception
and you're in some sense escaping from
the the limitations of reality that's
the imaginary okay and it and it sort of
maps onto what Tolkien meant by
um Escapist fantasy yeah and then the
imaginal is Imagination for the sake of
enhancing perception and the the given
deep learning and predictive processing
this now makes tremendous sense right
most of perception is imaginable in this
sense yeah so yeah go ahead so if I may
just comment that
um this is precisely distinction I make
between what I call imagination and
fancy following following words with
encourage
um the greatest writers in the English
language on this particular topic and
what they meant was the distinction
exactly between fantasy that takes us
away from reality and Imagination which
is our only chance to enter into reality
right and there's a and there's a
connection I believe
uh I know Coleridge has a huge influence
on Barfield and I believe there's some I
don't know if it's directly between
Barfield and Corbin but I think they
both influenced Hillman and others so
I'm aware there's connections between
those two bodies
no importantly the uh coverage and
coverage wasn't the beginning of this
because he learned a great deal from
shelling
um and more or less lifted some of it
out of shelling
um so it goes down the line from there
to in our time or more recent time
anyway Owen Battlefield and and so on
yeah and I think wartoff is right that
it actually goes back you can see it in
Gutter and when good is trying to get
the herb plant
he's inventing the imaginal act of
perception uh yes it's a very good point
and he also makes distinctions which are
remarkably apt about the difference
between the world provided by the right
and the world provided by the lifetime
incidentally so there we are anyway so
the point I was making and so for
example when I'm teaching but thank you
for that enrichment Kurt you wanted to
say something should I continue or I
want to see if this is correct so the
imaginary versus imaginal the difference
is one of intent the reason why is like
if one plays video games they're
escaping or they can be but yet they
still acquire skills that they can use
in the real world under the right
circumstances right
um but it's also what the phenomenology
of the act so let me let me try and say
so usually the uh the the imaginary
involves picturing in your mind like if
I ask you right now imagine a sailboat
are the sails up or not down and you can
say they're up or down you can tell me
that whereas if a child is imagining
being Zorro they are not picturing
anything they're picking up a stick
tying a blanket around them and they're
taking on the salience Landscaping of
Zorro getting a taste of what it would
be like to have zoro's perspective to
have zoro's identity and see what that
feels like for them in terms of skills
they might want to cultivate identities
and roles they might want to enter into
it's it's it overlaps with developmental
play and so the phenomenology is also
very fundamentally different
um I use it when I'm teaching Tai Chio
when I'm telling people to stand I say I
want you to imagine that you're standing
in a river and from your knees to your
feet are sinking into the mud
so you're kind of get that feeling of
rootedness and then from your knees to
around your navel just like flowing
water because that's how you want that
area if you bought and from here up is
like air you want to give it very little
attention and it dissipated and that and
that helps people get into the proper
way of inhabiting their body in order to
optimize it for you know Tai Chi Chuan
for sparring now that that for example
that's one example of how the imaginal
helps uh ratio but hirschfield and
others just just you give you give you
go into people the academics who are
supposed to be the best right and you
give them clear argument and evidence
that they should start saving for the
retirement you make sure they understand
you allow them to voice any disputes you
get agreement from them all
you come back in six months none of them
are saving for the retirement
then you do the following and of course
you have control groups and everything
I'm just giving the the experimental
group you ask them
to imagine their future self as somebody
that they love and care about
that somebody that they have a
relationship and a responsibility to a
member of their family
you come back in six months and you'll
find two things they are now saving and
the people that were vividly imagined
that future self were able to save even
more and you say so what the ability to
Aspire to your future self and this is
Agnes calart's argument is Central to
rationality rationality is ultimately
about self-correcting it's about
aspiring to get to become more rational
wiser than you are and therefore the
ability to properly Aspire is dependent
on the imaginal yet it is Central to
rationality and therefore they are
inseparably bound together this is
something I think Plato deeply deeply
understood because he'll give an
argument and then he'll give the he'll
give the parable of the cave and he'll
put the two side by side so your wife
right the imaginal and the rational are
interwoven together and again said we
have we have now set them into this
weird opposition which doesn't actually
make very much sense I suppose it could
be because of the prevalence of
entertainment in which uh the imaginary
or the fanciful is taking priority over
places in which people properly enact
be imaginal and I propose to you that
those places traditionally have been
ritual the serious play of the imaginal
in order to enhance people's sense of
connectedness especially to their future
self
of course there's an enormous amount
that could be said about the imagination
and its qualities and how it enables us
to feel our way into the being of
something other whereas fantasy Builds
on the things that we already know
putting them together yes putting them
together in a new sort of way and and I
use the analogy of those children's
books in which there are animals and the
pages are divided into three from top to
bottom and you can turn over as many as
you want of each part and you get the
head of a goat and the body of a seal
and the tale of a lion or something and
and that's that's fantasy that's just
putting together stuff that doesn't
really exercise our imagination but
words with famously was
thought
um in a way foolish risk being the
person Wittgenstein said we all should
be here and For Heaven's Sake don't stop
being foolish what he did was he looked
at a very
um Bleak looking
Cliff or Rock
and in his contemplation of it it became
something more real than yes when we
just look it's easy for us now at this
stage in life and this is what
Wordsworth wrote about in his own on
informations of immortality that as we
grow up we cease to be an immediate
contact with things because we're in
contact of our images of those things we
have a category we go to a picturesque
scene and instead of being completely
blown away by the beauty of it we're
already categorizing picturesque scene
mountains that's right a lake and so on
and it's this process of getting beyond
words and beginning Beyond a categorical
thought towards the very experience that
we're having that is so important
so I I I I no I think that's right and
for me
um
I'm not here to criticize woodsworth or
or my favorite uh poet rilka who does
something very similar uh favorite
person of mine as well by the way he is
yeah yeah uh and uh but I guess for me
part of the question becomes uh when I'm
trying because I I not only I'm a
scientist I'm also a person who's
involved with a lot of these emerging
communities in which people are trying
um individually and collectively to
build the colleges of practices for
responding to the meeting crisis and
doing it a good faith I'm not talking
about the charlatans I'm not talking
about the exploiters I'm not talking
about the gurus I'm talking about people
like Ray Kelly and uh and others uh and
you know and I that recently with them
in Vermont uh we're trying to organize
things together
what what what I what I why I bring that
up is to me the the question becomes
how do we
reverse engineer and recommend practices
for people individually and collectively
such that this is recoverable to them
not only in thought but in actual
conscious engagement with themselves
other people in the world
I've got a couple of thoughts about that
um the first is that I don't think that
practices in themselves will ever
achieve what needs to happen because
they can still go on without the mind
and heart of the person having
fundamentally shifted
and in a way the reason that religions
have rituals and practices is that if
you think your way into feeling those
things eventually eventually and live
them in your life then things will begin
to change but I'm worried that
recommending practices to people like if
you do so much meditation per day and if
you you know spend so long in nature and
you spend so long listening to music
there's nothing wrong with any of these
things but the trouble is that as
Einstein said we can't get out of the
particular mess we've produced with the
same thinking that got us into it in the
first place and so we need to shift
entirely what we
um meaning by meaning and another point
that occurs to me is these these people
that you mentioned that are not
charlatans and have something wise to
say I think it's an enormous load to
place on any one individual that their
ideas their practices their set of
whatever it is can really reach wisdom
in the way that
tradition that has
absorbed and evolved with and changed in
the process ideas of many many people
wise people who live before us that is
more likely in the end to distill wisdom
which is why I think that I don't think
it's necessarily very easy to do that's
not impossible but to do it without some
sort of a tradition it doesn't have to
be Christianity of course it might be
um none of the monotheistic religions
good as they are it might be taoism or
Buddhism and so on with their history
with their teachings with their Parables
with their practice
it just is I'm a little more cautious
about the idea that either you or I
however bright we are can sort of really
take it upon ourselves to recommend to
people how they can acquire wisdom in
fact one of the points about wisdom is
it can't be acquired according to any
process
okay this sounds like a great point of
disagreement as much as there are
agreements because I know you have
non-theism which sounds like well why
don't you explain what non-theism is or
if you want to respond to that John well
I do want to respond to it first of all
I I wasn't proposing practices in place
of also fundamental philosophy I was
practiced I was proposing something very
much like what you see in stoicism
um in which or in Buddhism or in
neoplatonism you have both a fundamental
philosophy and a set of practices that
are integrated together
um and I also think whatever that
integration is also has to be in deep
and good faith dialogue with science
especially uh the the cognitive Sciences
because those are what I would call
cognitive science because those are the
ones directed towards helping us
understand the very processes of meaning
making
um so that's the first part of the
response I I think and that's exactly
what I'm trying to offer I'm trying and
this is how
a lot of these people are taking this
taking these packages is up they're not
taking them up as just Panacea practices
they're taking it up as oh no no no we
need to be doing uh we need to be doing
a lot of attentional sensory motor a lot
of stuff and a lot of philosophical
reflection and a lot of dialogue if
we're going to get something and
properly enter into dialogue with the
existing wisdom Traditions so that's
part of what I meant by uh how these
communities are working for example I
was at uh this conference was being held
at the maple monastic Academy which
comes out of the Zen tradition is deeply
influenced by it but wants to talk to uh
some of the you know some of these
emerging uh communities that have come
out out of other traditions secondly
um
uh I do think uh and we I do think that
we are in a place that might be like the
place where some of these
and this is a this is this is uh a
somewhat Preposterous proposal uh but
it's a historical I think we're in a
Kairos I think we're at a pivot point
um in our civilization because I think
the meaning crisis
um weakens us disables us in the face of
addressing the meta crisis uh in in many
powerful ways
um and and then the meta crisis feeds
back and makes the world seem Bleak and
in ahospitable for people wrestling with
meaning so I think they're interlocked
and so I think we're in a Kairos because
as you think actress is real and
accelerating and I do think the capacity
for social media to misdirect us is real
and accelerating
so my point is when we're in a Kairos we
may need to give birth to something new
all of these other great traditions did
start somewhere you know Socrates of the
neoplatonic tradition Jesus and the
Christian tradition Muhammad and Islamic
tradition I'm not claiming to be any of
these speakers and I I will not accept
any any attempt of job description of
that for me what do you do it but but I
know and nor do I think that any of
these I know Ray Ferry uh for example
rape as part of his practice makes sure
that he steps out of the leadership role
other people he also does not see him
none of the people are talking to see
themselves what they do think is that
something is emerging right now and
because of the urgency of the situation
uh we should try to interact with it as
best we can
to try and see if we can steer it to
becoming something that is a viable
response for the growing demographic
group of people who cannot find the
Legacy religions a proper home for the
cultivation of wisdom so that would be
my response
yes
but I I wouldn't really disagree with
that and thank you for your
clarification right which really just
confirms under what I hoped that you
might say about it was really more a
clarification because I think it's easy
for people to think I'm often asked you
know after lecturing so what do we do
right away you know what do we do now
yes and yeah and it's like the left
hemispheres job is to solve an immediate
problem and it wants eight bullet points
and if we can do all of those
phew we can carry on business as usual
but my message is we cannot conceivably
carry on business as usual and I'm not
talking about anything that can be
um summed up as a series of um steps
that we should take there are steps that
we should take that are very practical
we must stop poisoning the oceans we
must stop destroying the forest we must
stop
um extinguishing the ways of life of
indigenous peoples we there's many many
things we should do we should stop
actually attacking and destroying all
that's best actually out of our own
civilization there are many things that
we we need to do rather urgently but
that's not really what I'm saying I'm
saying we need to think about the
business of thinking and what we mean by
meaning and that these need to be
reconceived and the way that I like to
reconceive them is by
unfailing over a long stretches we both
acknowledge and I apologize for the
length of what I write but over a long
stretch but but yeah you're different
right you're a good writer so I mean I I
don't I don't want people I don't want
people to be put off by that I I mean so
I just wanted to sorry for interrupting
but I don't I know I I we both did yeah
it's a long book but you're a good
writer uh so I don't yeah I don't want
people who put off by that anytime you
want to interject a compliment of course
but really what I'm saying is that I
think it's a question of at the
beginning of the book I say in a very
short note to the reader which is only a
page and a half long I I think of it as
taking somebody on a journey through
which they can see something from
different perspectives and that that
will in itself bring about a kind of aha
moment
wow this is how it looks from here and
it's not because I've explained
something and asked you to ascend to a
property position it's because I have
suggested I have indicated I've taken
places I'm going to go over an advanced
array of things from literature from art
from Philosophy from you know all the
rest but I think it's that process of
actually guiding people towards a
different position that I think is key
I agree and for me that's the that's
where we're getting into perspectival
and participatory knowing as opposed to
propositional ascent
and I and thank you for agreeing with my
clarification I just want to uh
reciprocate I definitely did not mean a
bullet point I think DC Schindler he he
indicates that that is one of the uh in
his uh Plato's critique of Imperial
reason he indicates that's one of the
markers of Mythology the hatred of the
logos which is right a kind of
intellectual impatience a profound kind
of no I'm talking about that the only
thing that will resolve the meaning
crisis is a way of life the way
kirkegaard and vickenstein and soccer
exactly meant it to be but the problem
I'm saying is where do people go to get
you know
the sets of practices Transformations
and community relations that afford them
entering into a new way of life that's
for me the pressing question uh and
that's what I'm trying to and as I see
people trying to create ways of life
within communities and a reconciliation
with the scientific worldview such that
they can be properly cosmically homed
and that's that's what grabs my interest
that's what I want to try and support
yes and I if I may I'd like to emphasize
the idea of a way
as never completed and always being
newly undertaken so it is a it's a
process I I I
happen to believe that all the things we
call things are in fact in process and
that is therefore very important to see
that process because when we talk about
a way and needing a way and of course
taoism is named after that way which is
a practice that needs to be lived and
when
um Christ said I am the way the truth
and the life he didn't mean once you
believe in me you got it he meant there
is a way yes you can enter into through
so we believe in what he was teaching
and in what he showed by his example
that would take one where one wishes to
go I deeply agree with that so much so
that I have said please carve on my
Tombstone neither Nostalgia nor Utopia I
do not think uh anything that claims to
have a total grip and a resolution in
fact and perhaps this will slide into
the topic I think we need to think of
the sacred as an inexhaustible source of
intelligibility rather than as some
state of perfection
yeah I I didn't think we'd find much to
discuss there because we're completely
in agreement about that I just wanted to
say for me uh that's exact that's
exactly what I see exemplified I mean
that you know you know people talk about
the Socratic method there's no such
thing there is a Socratic way there's a
Socratic way of life and and Socrates
was so uh faithful to that way of life
that he was willing to die for it but he
does he undermines all attempts to
replace what he's doing uh with a method
or any sort of totalizing vision and so
for me and again I practice uh uh like I
don't consider myself a Taoist but I've
been practicing Tai teach one and Qigong
uh or for close to three decades and and
towards a point I was making earlier I I
don't let me say it this way I don't
think you should do tai chi Chuan
without ruling the Tate Chan but I also
think you shouldn't Dutch read the taut
hm without doing patreon uh because for
me that's like reading the Kama Sutra
and never making love you you really are
you really aren't getting and putting
the two together and so
I I'm interested then if you agree with
me that
and by the way having a process view of
reality
you'd probably also influenced by
Whitehead as as I am
um
and right and and the idea that all all
that part of what is needed
and this is part of What's
um the the third wave scholarship around
uh neoplatonism and things like that but
is to
get out of a thingy way of thinking
absolutely well that's that's why my
latest book is called the matter with
things it's upon on a whole range of
things to do with uh oh I didn't get I
didn't get that second part I got the
matter our obsession with matter and our
obsession with things and the matter
with things now so it tries to bring
together a number of elements but I I
just wanted to also throw into the mix
and see if you agree with me here
that a lot of what we've been talking
about is predicated typically for the
Western mind on the idea that there are
things good things that we can do
and uh I always think that we need to be
careful of thinking that it's doing that
causes change it may be receiving and
there is something that I choose to term
active passivity which is not just a
kind of let it all hang out thing but
actually a disciplined attention to the
world
um I always come back to attention
because I believe it's a moral act and
changes the world and changes
us who do the attending so it's a very
very important thing and in that open
attending we come to hear things and we
can crowd them out I sometimes give the
image of a you know a gardener not
actually being able to make a plant of
course definitely no but what a gardener
can do is allow the plant to be stifled
or remove things that would get in the
way of the plants thriving and that's
really what a gardener is and we are
like that
shoes and spiritual depth and meaning
and wisdom come to us and we either
drive them out with our noisy
logicizing and rationalizing and what
they call Monkey mind as you know in
yeah yeah in Oriental traditions and
instead we should cultivate excitedness
really is one of the things I like about
where I I live on sky is it's a you know
probably silent
so in the analogy with the plant the
gardener is doing something though
you're making an analogy about attention
so is there another analogy where it
doesn't require doing because you're
trying to show the act itself is not
what we should be pursuing you you you
you're very good to pick that up and I
was hoping that you wouldn't
uh it is it is like being
um well I think actually
you know teaching is is a responsive
business so apparently you are saying
things but partly you're also receiving
things and as an exchange and I think
that a proper Gardener attends to what
the gardener is looking at but doesn't
rush in there kind of I mean
pulling it up to see whether its root
system is working properly according to
the science is not a good way to improve
the life of a plant so there's a certain
degree of standing off I think is the
way I would put it holding back of being
careful to preserve rather than rushing
in
well I want to answer I don't want to do
oh sorry did I cut you off again sorry
no I was just going to say that it's
something that some
ring the bell for me as a doctor because
in my training I was constantly told I
mean although doctors are always doing
things that
um first of all one shouldn't rush in
and apply things
um but also that in making a diagnosis
the first thing to do is to stand back
and look
and allow things to come to observe
things and only then do you even lay a
finger on a patient and only as a last
resort do you send for an investigation
to confirm or disconfirm the conclusion
you've received so even somebody as
Interventional as a doctor if they're
going to be good has to be able to
receive things and there's a
psychiatrist of course which is what I
ended up as
that's doubly true
okay okay I want to respond because I do
think cultivation is actually an
excellent uh metaphor
um and I I if you'll notice I always say
the cultivation of wisdom uh I'm very
careful about that precisely that Rising
reason
um and so uh first of all the the uh you
know conversions across very different
cultures at the heart of neoplatonism is
this idea of cultivating a profound
receptivity
um taoism you have Wu way which is the
profound uh receptivity I'll be liking
being like the uncarved block uh it's uh
at slingerland's book trying not to try
and that's what I would say to you Kurt
um the doing is a doing that undermines
itself is doing which sounds like a
paradox but when you do it like when
when you if you want to get into the
Flow State and you keep trying to get
into the Flow State you will never get
into the closing it doesn't mean being
limply passive you have to do in a way
that undermines it as a doing so that
you find yourself caught up in the Flow
State and then you flow which is not
something you do it is something you
participate in and I think getting that
what stagmire calls that proper
orientation which is I think what ratio
religio is is the the key thing and
that's Iris Murdoch and the sovereignty
of the goods speaking from the
neoplatonic tradition right that the
most important moral act the the the the
core moral Act is how giving things
their proper attention uh and she makes
that argument as the key to ethics and
how it has been largely ignored by the
analytic ethical tradition that had been
growing up right in the 20th century and
and I think that is fundamentally right
I think uh and I think that and virtue
ethics I think is moving towards that
that and because Murdock also said you
know love is when you when you finally
acknowledge that something other than
yourself is real and and right and so
it's this this this this this ability to
get oneself into a a receptivity to flow
such that one is properly evolving one's
attention to conform
in the Aristotelian sense to the
ligaments of reality I think that's the
ultimate thing that uh I'm trying to
talk about a lot when I'm talking about
relevance realization and etc etc
yeah I I just like to add a little
um writer to all of this which is that
there is Wu way is puzzling to
westerners initially because it means
not doing basically and and there is a
not doing which is quite different from
passively not doing something that is
the other side of doing just as there's
an unknowing which is not ignorance that
comes before knowing but the unknowing
that comes after knowledge sure and
there's an innocence that is not the
same as the innocence of a child but an
innocence that can only come after deep
experience of life and is what one
recognizes in truly deep wise spiritual
figures I agree and and uh I argue that
you know Socrates claiming that he knows
that he does not know comes to fruition
in Nicholas of kuza's learned ignorance
yes uh right exactly that and and yes
it's a it's a profound way of
and for me it's a profound way of being
able to exercise this discernment
platinus talks about the the nothingness
that is a privation and then the no
thingness that is a superlative the
really real and that you need a certain
proper kind of educating of your
sensibility and receptivity
to be able to discern nothingness from
No thingness and when you could when you
could do that that leads to a very
well one of the most profound kinds of
connectedness there there can possibly
be and that emptiness
um yes that is uh famously
um thought through Buddhist practices is
isn't as you say is not an emptiness in
the sense of the just nothing nothing
positive it's it's the uh the the word
in Sanskrit
um
um has the roots V which relates to a
seed that is swelling and it's interior
and life is coming forward or a womb The
Emptiness of a womb that will be the
fertile space exactly exactly and and
the root word for compassion in the
Hebrew tradition is being womb-like uh
for exactly the same uh absolutely yes
so yeah that's exactly it but the point
I was making is to your point about
westerners like you have to develop this
isn't quite the right word but if you'll
allow me to pour a lot through
conveyance into the word you have to
develop the taste for that difference
um and it's like it's not a thought it's
more of that I mean it requires thought
but it's more but like for me I D I
could not understand Wu way until I've
been practicing Tai Chi Chuan for like
over six years because when I started oh
that's it that's it there and and and
what's amazing is that's what comes out
when you're sparring if you try to spark
you'll lose but if you woo way into
sparring you'll do a great job
be in the full State well it needs that
pregnant emptiness that Ian's talking
about that gives birth to what is needed
appropriately at the moment
okay and that's called no thingness
I've noticed a signologist but I I think
that means non-action it means yeah that
means not doing not doing exactly but
but the metaphors are still the the
metaphors are pregnant emptiness they
give birth and when I was proposing they
line up with uh very much the alerted
ignorance and the no thickness of the
neoplatonic tradition Nicholas accuser
platinus Etc
I I I'm not I'm not a perennialist I'm
not claiming that they're all saying
exactly the same thing but I'm saying
there's deep convergence from very
different traditions and histories that
makes plausible the place they get to
well they come said to The Perennial
philosophy can be on the one hand
exaggerated and on the other under
respected uh yes there is a great deal
in common between the Traditions there
of course not not exactly the same and
that's the wonderful thing about
people's different traditions and
different perspectives looking at
something that is recognizably the same
but from each perspective something new
will be added to our understanding of
what it is in fact that's my idea of
what objectivity is it's not
um a rather peculiar state in which one
denies the humanness of the Observer who
is the only one who knows all this stuff
that one's calling objective
that would be a very very strange way of
looking at the world not necessarily the
revealing of truth but what seems
important is not to be
um as it were solely indebted to one
perspective but to be able to see a
number of perspectives and to allow them
to complement one another and that in
that sense one of them will be this one
in which one is trying to eliminate
forcibly one's own person in the
encounter with whatever it is it's a
strange thing to do but it it's worth
doing but it doesn't in the end uh as
modern physics tells us it doesn't in
the end
um work out as the the best way to
understand the material or immaterial
world yeah I agree wholeheartedly with
that I think
um
I think I'm deeply influenced by Nago on
this the attempt understanding the view
from nowhere no but but in the Absurd
yes sir he basically argues that the
view from nowhere also generates the
Absurd right yes the perspective of a
Flash and so there's something there's
something paradoxical if our our
fundamental guiding metaphor of
objectivity is the same one that gets us
into finding reality absurd because
science is depending on the
intelligibility
and I just want to gloss what I said
because it's very very important that
I'm not misunderstood I don't think that
the term objectivity has no job to do I
think it's a very important term and
what it means is arriving at the most
rich most true perception of what it is
one's looking at and that means not
allowing oneself to be swayed by some
completely extraordinary biased way of
looking at the world so I know I'm
equally opposed to that and just because
the clinically detached impossible view
of the non-person is not possible
doesn't mean that it's free for all for
any point of view not at all some points
of you are Dreadful noxious but not only
on true but damaging other points of
view may be rich welcoming and unfolding
of life and vitality and creativity yeah
I I and again I'm in agreement with you
um because I was not I was not proposing
a rejection of the notion of objectivity
no no no I was proposing to reject a
particular model that has held captive
you know beckenstein's liggenstein's
idea about a picture holding us captive
yeah no I knew you weren't saying that I
just wanted for everyone's sake to make
clear that neither of us were were
really putting down that particular
Rabbit Hole of postmodernism in which
every every point of view is equally
valid absolutely no no no at some points
absolutely absurd others are
extraordinarily deep so so my view my
view on this is deeply influenced by
Confluence of sort of of uh the the
third wave of platonic scholarship and
Marlo Ponte
um and the idea uh first of all
so here's a thing and first of all
realize that you can never see the whole
thing you can never see the whole thing
no matter where you look at it right
there are multiple aspects and they're
not only multiple aspects in terms of
its visibility there's multiple tactile
aspects there's multiple auditory
there's multiple uses of this and then
what you start to realize is that there
is multi-ess factuality and then not
only is it multi-respectuality within a
person there is multi there are multiple
perspectives on any one thing this is
why dial logical reason is so important
and then for me what you're trying to do
and this is Marlo ponte's sort of
critique of historal you're trying to
find the through line
because what you realize is that right
the these this doesn't come off as a
cacophonous you know Cubist painting
there's a Melody here and it's not this
is not logically identical to this or
this or this but nevertheless there is a
through line of intelligibility what
John Newsom calls a musicality to it and
for me
um and it's inexhaustible it's
inexhaustible that leads to the idea of
the person as continuous
um idea that our lives are made up of
moments like time slices but they're not
they are like a melody as as only
Belgium said that one's personality has
this exactly nature of a Melody which is
always unfolding and and that um that's
a very important Insight but thank you
because that's the point I want what for
me objectivity is when I have this
melody as you put it in sync with that
Melody yeah there's a continuity of
contact yeah so that I can I can within
my finite Transcendence as how as
Highland puts it I can disclose as much
of that inexhaustible multi-ess
factuality and multi multiple
perspectives as I possibly can within a
integrated intelligibility
that that's that's the proposal that's
coming out of people like Marlo Ponte
how we should re-underst and I think
it's actually Plato's proposal uh I
think I think I think Gonzalez and
Highland and Kirkland and all of the
third wave are right on about that and I
think that is how we should and that's
not that's a non-thinky way of thinking
again because the through line is not
any aspect it is not any perspective
precisely because it is that which binds
all the aspects and all the uh all the
perspectives together and for me one
needs all those perspective says what
um Russell called admirations of the
thing one needs to see it from as many
exactly exactly exactly exactly but
without uh as I say this ridiculous idea
that anything goes and do you know the
uh the Japanese zen garden riyanji
uh it it's a very beautiful garden it
has 15 rocks set out in the in the sand
and from wherever you stand in the
garden the most you can ever see is 14
of them
okay so I love it
Nicholas acouza when he writes the
vision of God and he sends it to the
monastery he sends a painting
and no matter where you stand in the
room it looks like the painting is
looking at you and then he says first
everybody do that and then do the
following one monk stands in one place
and another Monk stands in the farthest
other place and they both claim that the
picture is looking at them and then he
says
go ahead no that's just true of any
painting where you exactly it's nothing
special it's just this phenomenon here
oh the eyes are following no they're not
it's just that wherever you look you
think the face is looking at you
so he
but he he well I think that's the point
uh because then he says
now try to what would it be like to be
able to realize this all at once and of
course you can't but he says that's what
it is to have the vision of God it's not
to see God it's to see the way God sees
right it's to see that through line that
you can't actually see because it makes
all seeing possible Right
and so this is again the non-thingness
that is not privation but is the
inexhaustible found with which from
which intelligibility flows and flows
and I think for me that has been that
has been my fundamental
phenomenologically rich and reflective
experience of the Sacred to exactly find
that and for me Gerta is is talking
about that when he's looking at the
plants and I see the same thing when
when you in the platonic dialogues you
have this Quest right to find the virtue
but you never get to the answer but you
get the through Line running and all
that sort of thing for me and like you
said that's when I find the sacred in
another person when I realize that
there's there's multi-aspected
multifaceted but there's a through line
and I can hear it and taste it and
follow it but I can never complete it or
grasp it totally and if I say that to
her I've destroyed the relationship so
that would be the most foolish thing to
do but I as you said everything is like
that and that means we can fall in love
with being again it's not like for me
that's a real possibility for people
I'm sorry that that that's for me what I
I I think is if we could enable people
read through a way of life to fall in
love with being again I think that would
be a deep way of responding to the main
crisis
but certainly a rather nice way of
expressing it I agree and love is
probably going to be part of how one
achieves that and
and you you touched on that idea of the
not just the way God sees but of the way
we see God and I'm trying to think who
it was now was it it I'm not sure it was
Eckhart it might have been
Bonaventure or somebody who said you
know the eye with which I see God
Eckhart exactly yeah it's the same I was
which God sees me exactly but anyway yes
that's a a good point but how on Earth
um are we to if our is the subject we're
talking about is how to bring this about
how do we how do we help bring it about
or perhaps that isn't the question or
perhaps it's not even a good question
well I think it's whether or not it's a
well-formed question or not I think it's
probative
um one of the books that's had the most
profound influence on me is religion and
nothingness by nishitani and he it's a
fall and it's a masterpiece and it's
rightly regarded so it's a follow-up to
his earlier book The self-overcoming of
nihilism and to give you a flavor of it
there's another quote very similar to
eckhart's which was uttered by Nietzsche
uh if you stare long enough into the
abyss it begins to stare back into you
Nietzsche Came Upon something but he
gets to the edge of it but he doesn't it
doesn't flip over for him and what uh
what nishitani proposes is
um
he proposes that
and I I'm interested because you might
have a really interesting take on
Nietzsche doesn't doubt deeply enough
it's almost like the left hemisphere is
capable of this profound doubt but it
can never doubt its own authority or its
own preeminence or something like that
yeah so very much so yes yes
and and he proposes like one that one of
the practice one of the points of Zen is
to get the great doubt that drops you
beneath and then that profound resonance
beliefs The propositional Tyranny gets
disclosed to people and I think I think
that's
part of what needs to happen right now
I'm not saying I'm not recommending Zed
I'm saying we have to get something in
which we
we live in the hermeneutics of Suspicion
where we doubt everything except we
doubt the perspective The Stance from
which that happens and I've been trying
to figure out the semantic philosophical
Jujitsu moved right in order to get that
doubt to actually turn onto itself in a
profoundly transformative way without of
course destroying people's sanity or
lives of putting them into a psychotic
break or anything ridiculous like that
no of course but one of the things that
can break us out of that doubting of
everything
um is the experience the Transcendent
experience of something very real and
it's yeah in a way that comes as part of
it's one of these self-referential
things that you can't break into it
unfortunately because you can't cause
this experience to happen to you but you
can put yourself in the way of it
happening yes included and what worries
me is that the way we live now with our
attention so fragmented and ourselves so
bound up in verbal noise and discussion
about you know all the things we're
talking about one of the things that
troubles me actually about where this
conversation is going is that the wise
person stops talking at this point
because really we're entering the
territory where you cannot talk about it
so
um but we drown out the possibility of
being there for
whatever you mean by the sacred even for
the beautiful because you need to attend
to it deeply not just sort of allow it
to be in the background somewhere you
actually have to
have an encounter with it and it's that
that changes changes once one's way of
being
I suppose I agree with you and I I mean
I I do think what
there is an intermediary
which is to try and find people that are
exemplifying
an encounter with the really real and
there's a there's a large proportion of
the population in which that even
happens spontaneously at least 30 at
least 30 percent perhaps 40. so we've
got a culture that silences them but it
doesn't have to be the way there's no
necessity to that no you're right
so for me it's beyond a trend it's
beyond a mystical experience it's a
transformative experience so
um uh it's an experience in which
one
has many of the features of a mystical
experience the Oneness the the the the
the the the
hereness the numbness the altogetherness
the depth of realness but it's
ultimately ineffable but it carries with
it
um
um all the markers of being
real such that people do the following
they will they'll do something weird
normally when we have an aberrant State
of Consciousness that doesn't fit into
our everyday Consciousness we use that
to say it's not real like a dream or
being drunk but they do the opposite
they cut they have these experiences and
they say that was really real and all of
this is an illusion
and they then they say I'm the must is
not
a compulsive must it's what I call
autonomativity that they I need I need I
profoundly need to change who I am and
how I relate to the world maybe my
occupation my career they will
profoundly change their lives because
they want to be closer to that really
real they want to conform more to it and
yeadon's work shows by many objective
measures
their lives get better that's what I
mean by a transformative and uh Steve
Taylor has a book I think it's called
waking up where he taught he canvases
all of this it's not it's not it's not a
scientifically profound book but it's
great for just Gathering all these
accounts together no it's extraordinary
how common these experiences of
um well it even can be described as
encounters with God actually by a lot of
people even though they don't
necessarily believe in God at all but
they call them encounters with God or
with the cosmos with the ultimate truth
or whatever it is and they're
surprisingly common
well and and they are not predicted by
any kind of mental disorder and neither
neither do they generate any kind of men
no yeah no no the very important point
you've already made which is that when
people have hallucinations and delusions
when they're better they count them as
unreal and they see that they're better
off without them but after these
experiences they don't they they think
this is the this was the reality and it
often has long-term uh changing effects
on their lives exactly as you say so
it's something that needs to be taken
seriously and there is research and some
of it you've probably been mentioning
which which shows how very real and
important this is so we discount this
um because we're told that clever people
write people intelligent people don't
think like this it's just some
um ill effect of something misbehaving
in one's brain but it it's not an
adequate account yeah and I I go over
both I've given talks on this and
conferences I go over it in Awakening
for the meeting crisis on higher States
Of Consciousness I've talked that about
it at Yale Etc you can make a very good
case for this is actually a justifiable
claim I mean well
um I don't hang too much on the
propositions they come back with uh
because the propositions vary all over
the place but that sense I've done an
experiment in my lab where we like
what's the relationship nobody did this
which we thought I thought was
astonishing is there a correlation
between having mystical experiences and
how meaningful you find your life you
would have thought somebody had bothered
to test that it shows you the ignorance
of our orientation that that has not
never even been tested we tested it a
huge amp church study it is predictive
it's Coral it's correlative right and
but it's not the particular
phenomenology phenomological content
it's the Insight Machinery it's it's
very much in a continue think about when
you have an Insight right and you oh and
then you know why you were wrong before
but you can't know that until you go
through it right it's it's that it's
that kind of thing it's like it's like a
it's like a a systemic insight and a
systematic insight and what's
interesting is that the area in which we
have our moments the right Superior
temporal gyrus and sulcus is very close
to the area that has been repeatedly
found to be associated with
transformative religious experience
exactly the right temporary parietal
Junction effectively so I mean that's
interesting at every level but I feel
Kurt you need to help us reorientate
because we're talking about things that
well I just wanna I just wanted to talk
about I just wanted to follow up though
because right if we agree that this is a
real phenomena and if we agree that it's
not hallucinatory or something that we
can dismiss then like and then if we can
also find you know first of all if we
can support that culturally and also
watch people unfolding exemplary lives
this is sort of the socratic proposal
don't you know you know you know here's
a beautiful life
right the unexamined life is not worth
living here's a here's a beautiful life
and I think that's the kind of thing
that can attract people into what we're
talking about I I agree we can't we
can't give them here's how you do it but
what we can do we can we can cultivate
cultivate the people who are living
exemplary lives and create you know
communities where they Thrive that
attract people I propose we could do
that I I agree in in a way you've you've
given a description of what I aim to do
in my work which is to take people where
they see this is a beautiful vision of
life and it makes much more sense okay
so here's what an atheist may say or an
extremely staunched materialist may say
that sure you had an experience of
something real but your experiences can
be misleading and just because you had
potentially some psychedelic and you
feel like so and so is real well that
can be triggered let's say with
transcranial stimulation and other
methods so I can make you feel like
something's real when it's not so why
attribute realness to it just say it was
interesting so here's an example Sam
Harris said that he took an extreme
amount of mushrooms I'm not saying
anything that he hasn't said publicly
and then blindfolded himself went into a
room and he said he felt like he was
encountering something else but then
during and afterward he said well I was
saying well this is just me on drugs and
so I allowed it to take me whatever it
was some tiger or some other being I
allowed it to take me from realm to
realm but I didn't describe any realness
to it that also reminded me of this
quote I believe Ian you mentioned it the
last time you and John spoke on the
Rebel podcast
from Cars someone who Heidegger said was
the most important philosopher I don't
know if I'm pronouncing the name
correctly well James cause I didn't know
that how to get a new cars I I think
it's a different person okay okay you
said that Heidegger spoke at his funeral
John he said Heidegger spoke at his
funeral oh no that's that's Max Shayla
okay yeah he was Heidegger spoke at Max
shayla's Funeral and said that that Max
Shayla was the greatest European
philosopher of his Generation
Um which was uncharacteristically humble
of Heidegger
yeah
I think the connection was uh
reconstructive memory I had mentioned
that cars had just recently died I
believe oh so okay and then okay yeah
and that's uh you remember we put them
together in that fashion yeah yeah okay
so my two points are then Shaler perhaps
said I think it's trailer that you need
to open yourself up to knowledge rather
than having knowledge change you
something like that and it made me think
okay is it that someone like Sam Harris
is so closed to the Divine that even if
he encounters it he wouldn't see it and
he discounts it well that was just one
thought that came through my head and
then the next one was where it's
focusing so much on the nourishing
effects of these mystical experiences
but there is such a thing as totalizing
fear Terror and horror bad trips for
example whether or not they're even
trips and so then what's happening there
where one feels like yes what I've
encountered is real and I'm terrified
and I don't want that so those are two
separate points that I just wanted to
lay out there as potential jumping off I
think I think they're related but I'll
add and go first I think they are
related points yeah yeah maybe they are
and I think on the first point
um I would say uh yes of course
um the things that one
um once one's mind brings before one may
be deceptive but there but then often
they're also real and it's not it's not
enough to say well we just dismiss it
because sometimes it's going to produce
something very important and sometimes
it isn't the same is true of every way
of arriving at knowledge reason can lead
you down
um blind at it or what I call
rationality
um leading one's life by pure logic
um reduces it to to a meaningless mess
as
demacio's description of a patient
called Elliot he had to work everything
out from first principles yeah it had no
understanding of Life whatever so recent
but I wouldn't say well in that case I'm
not going to use the reason and I I have
the same same view about intuition you
know psychologists are amused by
developing very clever little scenarios
in which one's normally extremely
helpful intuition is deceived there are
going to be such things I can show you
optical illusions that are completely
unbelievable are those two squares on
that checkerboard really the same they
can't be but they are but I've never
heard anyone after seeing a very good
optical illusion say well that does it
I'm not going to use my open my eyes
then from now forwards because they
might be wrong so
the the mode in which something comes to
one doesn't say either it's got to be
right or it's got to be wrong we need to
examine the experience see what its
effects on us are and and what I'm
suggesting is that experiences that have
long lasting benign effects on somebody
oh not nothing and they are good which
is what the person believes they are
because what we're going to say is the
definition of this good experience if
it's not that it leads to good
consequences so
it's easy to dismiss things but that's
the lazy way you have to actually say
well some things no doubt deserve to be
dismissed some things don't
uh anyway
well I I want to buttress that first of
all yeah uh I I was thought I was not
reporting to argue give an argument from
the authority of a particular kind of
experience I think I think our culture
is I I don't think he desire I I think
our culture is beset by trying to find
the magical faculty that will give us
certainty this is a Cartesian wet dream
that we should abandon once and for all
um and also the other the other project
which is just this the flip side of it
finding the part the faculty that we
should demonize and scapegoat for all of
our failures I think we should give up
both of those projects they don't
comport well with how cognition works or
intelligence works or Consciousness
works so and I'm not saying you're
saying that Kurt I'm just responding to
your proposed uh perspective from The
Atheist
um
secondly
um I said I I am suspicious of the
claims the propositional claims that
come out of the content of these
experience precisely because they vary
in the way you say
um what I make an argument for is we
have good reason and to believe that
these experiences are actually on a
Continuum with Insight experiences flow
experiences experiences by which we are
optimally sort of getting a a meta
optimal grip on the world uh where where
we are engaging in a kind of direct
sensory motor feedback with the world
Etc yes Harris is right there probably
is no tiger in the room what was he but
he doesn't bother to ask what might have
been happening
he just says well here's the proposition
that I came up with it's false therefore
everything was wrong well how do we know
how do we know what like why doesn't he
bother to ask why is a tiger being
thrown up in my altered perception of
the room
yeah there's no tiger there but what if
you were to say what what if what's that
the very Act of coming up with the tiger
was connecting areas of cognition that
he bothered to explore could give him
some more fundamental insight into how
he is perceiving or framing things
that's how many people within these
wisdom Traditions would respond to him
they would say well why did you stop
there why did you stop there why did you
why why didn't you talk to other people
and I mean when you when you're when
you're trying to determine if anything
else is real you stop after one moment
of thought or do you do do you do a lot
of science yeah well firstly just to
clarify for the record I don't know if
what he's encountered was a tiger but it
was some other creature or being and I
don't want to spread misinformation but
that's that and then third and then
secondly you mentioned why didn't you
talk to other people okay interesting I
was speaking to Diana pasoka who's a
professor of religion and she was saying
Kurt something that's missing in all of
these modern
forms of religion which are spiritual
but not religious
is Sangha so a community yes totally
totally that's what I mean by Auto
didactic she said that that's even the
answer to Plato's Cave
then I asked her well is that in Plato's
Cave she said no it's in the Republic
and she gave me some explanation but
regardless from my understanding of the
non-theist position or neoplatonism I
think Peugeot says you can't simply
resurrect a religion from reading books
how is it that we become neoplatonists
is it truly a religion that you're
enacting well first of all I wanna I
wanna first of all pick up on the first
one yeah and I don't mean to be
misspeaking if I'm incorrectly no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no I mean
this is this is all this is at the core
of the whole dialectic and to deal over
this project that I've engaged in the
after Socrates the which is converged
from with all of this increasing
information that when people are that
reason I'll use Ian's word then is uh
evolved to be carried out dialogically
not monologically
multi-perspectively not model
perspectival right that we do not have a
magnetic self we have a fluid etc etc
etc
what's some of that evidence okay you
are you're familiar with the wasted
selection task right people smart
educated people you give them a very
simple
reasoning experiment and only 10 of them
get it right reliably no replication
crisis on this robustly take the exact
same thing Let There be four people and
they're allowed to talk to each other
the success rate goes reliably from 10
to 80 percent yeah yeah reliably that is
that is not exhaustive read uh the
Enigma of Reason by Mercer and spur bear
others this this overwhelming evidence
that we have we have this mana and
that's my point to to Harris never
questions I mean at least the Harris of
your example maybe it's not the actual
Harris right but I I don't want to
that's the name I'm going to use because
right he doesn't question the
monological frame from which he is
giving an answer and the point is well
that's not how reason evolved to work
reasons should be carried out and this
is a I think the core Socratic claim
dialogically no there's dialogue there's
the logos with other people
but you also have to practice the deal
logos within the psyche this is again a
proper platonic idea and those two
dialogues those two forms of deal logos
they have to be resonant with each other
in a profound way and for me that is
that is
most properly how to try and be as
reasonable as I possibly can Will it
give me certainty no but as Ian said
nothing does
right if your criteria is well that
could fail therefore I reject it then
you are an absolute soul of cystic
skeptic and then if you and if I ask you
okay what do you do to well I talk to
other people I reflect them I ask
questions I like well do that with these
experiences too nobody's telling you
take the experience and then just accept
it take these experiences put them in
this framework make sure independent of
this Frame of these experience that this
framework is working profoundly to help
you self-correct catch your bias catch
your flaws and then integrate the two
together and for me that's would make it
much more like a religion than just a
belief system in the modern
Enlightenment sense of a belief system
did that answer your question Kurt
generally it takes me days of reflection
to realize if something answered my
question
fair enough that's exactly that's
exactly right that's exactly the right
answer
no I I just think your point no well
first of all I think that it cannot be
overstated how important that point of
community is at the core of religion and
it's what is one of the roots of what we
started by talking about the meaning
crisis yes meaning is held by
communities that have common history of
common narratives common myths and a
sense of belonging which is you know you
talked I think
um about uh John about the um
I I don't know what you called it D
domiciled or something but I mean if
they can't decide yeah yeah we know we
no longer have a home we no longer feel
we belong somewhere and that sense of
belonging is part of meaning and one
gets it from belonging to a functional
family and belonging to a functional
Society there is no such thing as an
atomistic individual we emerge from
society and we give back to society and
we're in constant communion with society
and what a religion does is to
strengthen those bonds and the feelings
of empathy which lead to extraordinary
effects on cognition on emotion on
well-being including physical well-being
and mental well-being obviously and the
evidence about this is so strong and
it's not widely known but I give it in
the very last part of um of the matter
with things so I think that's a very
good point I think another point is that
we we shouldn't over emphasize the
importance of you know mystical moment
we may or may not have them I mean a
very important thing is that many
spiritual people have never experienced
these things but are deeply good and
wise so there and many people who have
achieved that state say you know if you
have a some sort of a you know a vision
or something that's great but really
forget about it and go back to getting
on with religion so it's the kind of
icing on the cake it's the in a way it's
slightly too much of a lure for people
nowadays oh you know I want some
Sensational experience but it's not
really about The Sensational experience
the next thing I'm sorry because I've
been holding back on them yeah yeah yeah
I'm trying to say them very very quickly
another is that I think that what
happens when one takes psychedelic drugs
people have sometimes said to me does
this not shut down the left hemisphere
and at least the rate not at all in fact
most um aberrant versions or or
peculiar versions unusual versions of
reality in this sense of hallucination
to delusions Anyway come from the left
hemisphere something I go into the very
fast part of the matter with things but
I think what happens is that the frontal
lobes are relatively shut down and I
think there's Imaging evidence that this
is the case so this lower
um circulation in the frontal lobe and
of course what the frontal loves are
above all is a filter and when you stop
filtering what the brain is proving to
then you get good and bad you may be
lucky and have a good experience you may
have a terrible experience and and in
fact I believe that terribly although
the literature tends to stress the good
experiences terrible experiences bad
trips
um under reported in the sense that
they're not talked about but they're
very real and they happen an awful lot
so I I just wanted to make you know a
few points that we're getting off too
much onto emphasizing you know the very
unusual and to go back to this idea of
imagination in which you see into things
that you thought you knew and then
realize that you know them for the very
first time and that experience is a
sacred experience
so I want to pick up on two things that
you had said
um
that's what I that's what I meant when I
said I wasn't holding these experiences
up as authoritative and I'm also not
saying everybody should have them what
I'm saying is we need to have ways of
life that uh properly hone them and that
that are beautified by them I don't
think everybody has to have them but
that that like but
we should have ways of life in which
many people can benefit from some people
having them is what I would say yes and
then the second thing I would say is
um
look uh and then you know this Kirk
neural network overfitting to the data
what do you have to do you have to do
Dropout turn off half the nodes or you
have to throw noise in or Stephanie
Dixon people are impassing on it and
they on an Insight problem and you
literally put visual static into it and
they get the Insight or the the mild
mind wandering that helps people have an
Insight yeah you have to you you have to
throw some noise and the noise noise
isn't
noise is noise it's destructive it's
frame breaking that's horrific that's
why the the the the sacred always has a
terrific or horrific aspect to it eyes
connected to awful
for good reason right but throat but you
you know the reverse if you don't ever
throw any noise into the neural network
what happens it overfits to the data it
doesn't generalize it fixates it gets
locked into a local minimum I would be
posted and Woodward and other people do
that we have we have you know we can
have psychedelic experiences or
meditative experiences or sensory motor
experiences that break that do that
massive frame breaking but it's not just
a frame breaking that I don't think
people should just have these
experiences in fact I'm arguing the
exact opposite we need to have a proper
like a sapiential sacred Community
around them so that that frame breaking
is compensated with a lot of resources
for brain making that's what I'm trying
to propose that's what I'm trying to
propose
um I just wanted to comment briefly on I
agree with all that you said
um that the idea of putting interference
in is not that I just want to
distinguish between two possibilities
one I believe is wrong and that is the
idea that somehow distraction is what is
good going on there what is good there
is that you at last I'm not sure that
you know so we're constantly going
familiar familiar familiar I get it I
know what it is and that's a very
uncreative state that is what the left
hemisphere
um brings to us a representation of life
that is clear and comprehensible and
sanitized and what they in in
informational kind of distraction is is
it's not the distraction in itself it's
the the rattling of arcades that we
don't actually know what's going on here
exactly that's exactly that's exactly
what I'm saying
yeah I don't want I don't want I I don't
want Elliot's distracted from
distraction by Distraction what I meant
is like that that you disidentify from
the framing enough that it can break up
you put criticality exactly so it can
self-organize a nuke that's what I would
say I completely agree yeah
where does faith enter into this
when I hear much about unknowing I was
reading about Nicholas of kuza and
someone said either commentary on him or
he said you must strive upward
unknowingly where does faith enter into
this so what are you I know you have a
partner
um and you uh are you know what if I ask
you are you going to be faithful to her
and I'm not asking you to divulge
privacy right but are you talking to me
or are you I'm talking to you I mean you
you're you if you love somebody there is
a call to faithfulness does that mean
you have a complete account of them
no that's ridiculous does it mean you
have an absolute certainty about them no
they're going to surprise you again and
again and again meet people that have
been married 25 years deeply in love and
they'll say man my partner can surprise
me again and again I never it's never
done it's never done this is my this is
my experience right so faithfulness
Faith doesn't mean I have certainty it
doesn't mean that I have a completion of
you that I rasp you that I can
manipulate you at will in fact it means
ah it doesn't mean any of those it means
that I have bound myself to you so that
I understand that there are truths about
you that will not be disclosed to me
unless I'm willing to undergo
transformation in relationship to you
and and allow you to do the same with me
these are transformative truths that are
disclosed by maintaining a continuity of
contact and an understanding that we are
going to reciprocally open with each
other
learned ignorance is the place at which
you are most able to do that with the
ground of being you are you are
reciprocally opening to its
inexhaustibleness and you are being
reciprocally transformed by that opening
again and again it's not that you come
to some some conclusive statement that
you can make it is the same kind of
sense you have of the depth of
connectedness you have to somebody you
have been faithful to and it grows the
longer you've been faithful and they've
been Faith you've the the language that
we've been together
I don't we should give up the idea of
Faith as the assertion of things without
evidence there's all kinds of evidence
in your relationship but if I was to say
could you deduce or induce or abduce
that you should stay with your partner
because of this evidence you'd say no
that's ridiculous it's way more than
that and that's exactly the faithfulness
element
Ian this reciprocal opening the way that
I imagine or the way that one generally
imagines God is that yes you can open up
to God but it's not as if God is
changing because of you now I know that
that means that there's a static view of
God and perhaps we should we're away
from that yeah that we don't know that
um I actually believe with Whitehead
that the World by which he meant the
whole experiential Cosmos and God
are coming into being together
reciprocally and that we therefore have
a part to play a very important part so
it actually matters how we respond to
the world what we make of it what we see
in it and what we give back to it I'm
just going to go and put a light on I
didn't want to do it well John oh yes
because it seems a bit rude but I'm just
kidding
not sure this doesn't make any
difference but night is falling here
um uh you kind of film The Walrus though
Ian I'm trying to work you're kind of
filming yeah
yeah you're lit on one side no that's
absolutely fine yes I like asymmetry as
you probably know
um so yes
um where were we we were talking about
you were talking about right head and
yeah and the reciprocal opening between
God yeah it's a typical opening so I
think that is a very important idea and
I think that another thing that um is
worth saying while talking about faith
is there is a similar duality in the
idea of belief so for example
um I can say I believe in a certain
person you know I really believe in him
it means I put my trust in him or her
and it and the point there is that there
is something about them that almost
places a responsibility on me to respond
but it also that very fact it also
places a responsibility on them to be
true to what it is I believe in you know
if they let you down then there has been
a failure of this relationship so that
what we are doing in life is always
assessing and helping to grow certain
relationships there is no certainty
about anything at all but that doesn't
make it blind yes this concept of faith
of blind needs to be put to bed once and
for all if I am forwarding a stream and
my companion has gone ahead across the
stream and as I get near the bank I need
a hand and he or she holds out a hand to
me it's not a random hand it's not like
blind to trust this hand I have to step
and I have to take the hand and and
that's that's the way I see it that you
see something that is calling to you and
saying if you understand this it will
radically change the way you think about
the world and there is no one right way
to know so just to say well I think I've
already got it and I'm not going to try
this at all I'm not going to put myself
in the way of something happening that's
really what I'm saying it has to be
experiential as John and I agree
but what that means is that you do have
a responsibility to put yourself in the
way of something happening
um you know if you sit at home saying I
want to marry but I'll never I'll never
meet any but you never ever leave the
home you'll never get married so if you
want to you you don't know who you will
marry it's entirely unpredictable it may
be chance what happens but nonetheless
you have to open yourself to the
possibility otherwise it won't happen
and the same I think is true of our
relationship with
with the cosmos at large which I believe
is a living
organismic entity a conscious entity
or God depending on what it is to be I
don't want to rule anybody's
um
attempt to make this encounter out just
because of a word
I wanted to pick up our the you know the
connections between you know trust
trough
truth we talk about being being
betrothed to somebody we talk about
being true to somebody there's deep
connections between these and and and
we've come up with the notion of faith
that is so disconnected from that
interconnecting set you know truth and
truth and Trust uh it's that that that's
just a fundamental mistake we need a
sense of that's why I propose the notion
of faithfulness because many people hear
something different in faithfulness than
they do to Faith because it connects
with that being true to right betrothing
yourself to somebody trusting yeah Etc
yes yes
good have you gone anywhere to answering
anything of your your questions I need
to think about this I generally think
more when I'm editing too do you hear
something interesting talking about the
Flow State there's also this adage that
we need to be more present and that life
will just pass you by if you're not
present however when one isn't at least
when I'm in the Flow State
maybe I'm present but life is certainly
passing me by in the sense that if you
stop me right now you say Kurt am I in
the full State I realize actually yes I
have been in the Flow State so much time
has passed by but I can consciously
remember little of it but that doesn't
mean that it's not implicit an estimated
over precise estimate of the amount of
the stuff that our brain is processing
is that only 0.6 percent of it is stuff
that we are aware of being aware of
so our self-conscious self-aware
awareness uh is the accompaniment to
almost all of our life it doesn't mean
it's not happening to us it doesn't mean
it's not changing us it doesn't mean
that we're not partaking in it it just
means that that bit of us in which we
stand back and consciously say I've been
in this state or I am in this state well
first of all doing that in the state
would interrupt it and it's again to
quote Whitehead he says that operations
of thought are like Cavalry Charges in
battle they need to be very rare they
require Fresh Horses and they're not a
solution to the way in which one carries
out a campaign so you know you
the fact that you're not aware but I
wanted just to talk about time because
there's a sense in which time is passing
in which we're outside the flow
objectively and we're watching things
happening and we have this image of
something moving past us but there's
another kind of being in the flow of
time where we're not standing on the
bank of the river with a clipboard and a
stopwatch measuring things but we are
actually in the flow we are literally
swimming with the river and as far as
we're concerned the river is not really
moving we're moving with the river so
relative to us as it where time is still
but in fact nonetheless the flow is
happening time is passing we are part of
it it just depends on whether we're
apart from it and imagining ourselves to
be stationary or taking part in it
yeah I I I don't have much to add to
that other than sort of a brooksonian
idea that when we when we
when we were start reflecting on time
and I'm not saying we shouldn't but we
lose time in and and you know I mean
this is this is the way to distract this
is the way to it's a sneaky way to win
when you're sparring with somebody
compliment what they just did
because then they'll stand back and look
at it and they'll become precisely
disengaged from it and then you win
because you've got to open it right
right
and because they're not because they're
it's an adversarial thing they're not
expecting a compliment you're a wicked
man Jones no I think it's actually it's
Oriental Oriental uh isn't it yeah so
yeah I I mean I'm not advised in doing
that I have done it and I have to say I
I once and I have seen that well maybe
more than once but not a lot of times
but just to make but the point I'm
making aside from my uh whether or not I
I fell into a vice is that
um I hope you know I'm joking well
that's why I'm laughing um so yeah uh
yeah I I think there's a sense
I mean Augustine said it famously I know
what time is until somebody asks me and
I'm not I don't want to get too much
into the philosophy of time but
there are I hope this doesn't come off
as a ridiculous pseudo-post modern pun
there are times when timing matters
and there's times when the future
matters I I think giving the advice to
always stay in the present moment is is
like that's not true uh I mean we we we
need a present moment that is bound
ratio religio uh to our future self we
have to pursue long-term goals uh Meyer
Smith and fishbach talk about you know
you have two different things you have
to do things inside a frame you have to
be able to self-regulate delay
gratification that's in the present
moment and mindfulness practices are
power meditative practices are powerful
for that but you also need to do frame
widening because you need to see if
what's happening in your present state
is concurrent not concurrent consonant
with your long-term future goals and
your future self remember the people who
don't save for their retirement you need
to balance properly between them and I
think that's what contemplative
practices do contemplative practices are
all often designed not to get us
immersed in the present moment in that
sense they're designed to remind us
about the comprehensive big picture in
powerful and deep ways and I put it to
you that what we're actually after is
Marlo Ponte sets up an optimal grip a
dynamic balance between those again that
for me is that is an essential dimension
of ratio religio how am I properly bound
to time
simplistic models I do not think give us
what is conducive to a good human life I
mean we don't we don't want to be wanted
right we don't want to be a creature of
your impulse because then we'll just be
destroyed right this is bellman's point
our agency will just be destroyed I
think that's absolutely not what many
exponents of the idea that we should
remain in the present are meaning not
that we should be you know Thoughtless
and never reflect and note that we
should be impulsive about all but that
we should be able in fact by us kind of
standing back to be more present to the
whole yes I think I mean I don't
disagree with your essential point I I
often think you know it's all very well
but we are the the creature that looks
before and behind you know and that is
our nature we are of beings who reflect
towards the person and the future so
yeah I agree deeply uh what I meant was
I know I I'm not I'm not disagreeing
with you I'm just saying that's the way
to think of it I agree I'm agreeing with
how you're agreeing with me okay
but no but Kurt I want to respond to
Curves sure
then what what I want to what what
because I
I
propose that many people are using the
slogan of being the present moment as a
license for impulsivity for
gratification or not long-term planning
or being Reckless for justifying going
for the Gusto and all other of the we
have a whole constellation of memes
around this right which is of course
designed to keep us buying stuff and
perpetually dissatisfied
um and that was the sense I wanted to
challenge okay so let me see if I can
tie a few threads together and weave it
back to the beginning
Ian when you said yeah there's a
misinterpretation of what it means to be
in the present moment
this is interesting because much of the
advice that I read in the comments
section not on toe videos well onto
videos but on other people's videos and
advice that I hear from quote-unquote
gurus and so on I'm interpreting it in a
certain way because I grew up in the
west and the way that they're
interpreting something in from an
English text which was already
translated and perhaps they have a
misinterpretation that I'm
misinterpreting what they're saying so
when some people say well I am God or so
and so on people say yeah I feel that
well you don't know if what you if what
they mean is what you feel and then when
I hear about we were talking earlier
about practices and rituals and they're
important you hear what we should do we
should be mindful more and this feature
list as you call them John this bullet
point list of what we should do
it's it's not entirely clear like I
believe in I used to believe in all that
let's say two years one
in my adult life until one year ago
because I'm such a liberal person in the
sense that I want everyone to be correct
like every culture is correct in their
way and everyone's touching a certain
part of the elephant it's just a
different part and and no one's wrong so
let me just let me take the the good and
and put in different pieces into me
however I feel it's as if
trying to install mac software on a
Windows computer like we're we're
windows and if you force an Exe on a Mac
no no firstly it won't load but if you
force it it will corrupt it and so I
think so much of what's gone incorrect
with me and perhaps with others because
as I talk about certain let's say
episodes of mine publicly people say oh
my gosh I've gone through something
similar and I haven't heard almost
anyone else talk about it and here's
what I've gone through
I feel like what's happening is that
we're being told so many lessons from so
many different places and they're not
unified and we're trying to apply them
to ourselves
so Ian you use this word marrying
earlier that you need to open yourself
up to marriage and earlier you talked
about traditional religion and Kurt his
entire adult life and his entire Teenage
life just an inexorable atheist and
uncompromising one one that's
condescending to anything that is
remotely superstitious or what I would
classify as superstitious would say no
there's nothing in traditional religion
that needs saving and if we're going to
formulate something that's a new
religion it has to be religion without
religion in John's word though I'm using
those words now I wouldn't have said
that before but I see that there's
something to marrying a religion what I
mean by that is when it comes to my wife
it's not like I evaluated every woman on
the planet and said this was the best
one there's going to be flaws with each
one so it's as if I had to decide that
she's the right one or create the right
one together with her I wonder if the
same is true with religion that part of
this is that we simply need to decide a
religion and then make it right for us
and it's not going to be right there's
going to be so much that they say that's
incorrect so that I'm just like no
there's like Adam and Eve didn't it's
not literal and why are you excoriating
Evolution constantly like this is not
how it is and I disbelieve that and so
on and so on there's so much that I
disbelieve but there's so much that I
gain from it there's so much that I gain
from having this community that's in
constant a tradition
so anyway those are some thoughts that
I'm laying out in a sense to tie what we
talked about in the beginning together
with some of the threads that were left
open throughout what are your thoughts
on that John do you want to start well
you were addressing the tea and I
thought he should respond first
Ian please
well I don't know which bit to respond
to but um
I mean first of all I think that there's
a huge problem and
um taking something that is clearly a
myth as literal truth I think that's a
very modern idea that you know we're so
used to talking only in literal terms
mean anything are not true that a myth I
mean the very word suggests that it's
false but now we only started using the
word in the 19th century and uh in fact
of course
um Mythos was anciently for the Greeks
the superior way of arriving at truth
logos was a secondary kind of Truth
which over time took over from it but it
was through through myth much that one
actually reached these deeper realities
that I think you're describing as
possibly being experienced by people in
religion
um the idea of marrying yes I mean uh of
course I'm not talking well I don't know
if I mentioned that I mean I was just
using it as an example but I I think
that the point there is that it brings
up the idea of something that is fitting
um Carpenters still talk about two
surfaces that meet perfectly as marrying
and they're fitting and it's this sense
of something that is a correspondence
that is attention or something that is
resolved in a new Union that something
is what we're describing uh as the the
meaningful encounter the faithful
encounter where something about the two
surfaces
produce something completely new that
neither surface on their own could even
conceive or never mind achieve
um
yes uh I mean
the way I would put that and um
is what you're doing in religion is
continuous with what you're doing in all
of your cognition which is relevance
realization which is about trying to fit
your framing to the world and it is not
given by you nor received by the world
but transjective it is made by the two
fitting together just like biological
adaptivity
you know Kurt that's how I use I use
that as a metaphor for the relevance
realization that I think is at the core
of our cognition and so what are you
doing with a myth I think you're doing a
kind of relevance realization myths
aren't
false stories about the paths their
imaginal stories to enable us to see
pertinent and profound and pervasive
problems and patterns that we are not
paying attention to myth and in that
sense is bound up with the proper sense
of Prophecy prophecy isn't telling the
future it's telling forth what needs to
be seen right now
deeply
and so for me like if you are getting a
lot out of it ask yourself kid and you
know the fact that whoever is giving you
the really silly sermon about you know
the Book of Genesis disproves Darwin or
something ridiculous than that I I mean
like if you can if if the myth comes
alive for you what's it doing I mean the
best the best myths
make us aware of the fact that we're
bound up in Mythos that we're bound up
in relevance realization that we're
bound to the world that we're connected
to it we're connected to each other and
and this connectedness we don't make it
we nor do we merely receive it we
participate in it we cultivate it and
and we have a deep and profound
responsibility to it because of how much
we belong to it and participate in it
and I think that's what
um when religion is functioning well it
uses its Mythos to do that can religion
malfunction of course it can everything
can malfunction science can malfunction
math was on this crazy thing where they
you know this whole project we thought
we could give a logical foundation for
math you know A Century of this crazy it
turned out just to be Impossible Project
we can go everything even math can go
down rabbit holes we gotta stop again
like hoping that we'll find perfection
as the mark of the Sacred with meaning
that in which we should trust
right God We Trust right we we we've got
to get more to this sense of fecundity
richness
when I do my neoplatonic practices The
Virtue that I the virtues that I
cultivate in them transfer very well to
my experience into my mind to my my
practices as a scientist and vice versa
and a lot of people this is now becoming
a viable philosophical position virtue
epistemology that actually what we're
doing in all of our domains is trying to
cultivate a set of Virtues that we can
apply across these many domains and so
for me
if it's doing that if the Mythos allows
you to cultivate virtues that percolate
through your psyche and permeate through
your life why are you like that's what
more could you want
what more could you want that's what
that's what I mean that's that that's
what you want when you marry someone uh
and I think we've got we've got to give
up I keep saying this we've got to give
up the hunger for completion for
certainty for comprehensive graphs we've
got to stop that and it's so it's so
endemic and Insidious you know thinking
it takes a lot of effort personally and
collectively to address that
Ian should we give up on all of
certainty or should we say oh I like
so-and-so because it's more certain I
don't have the idea that I'll ever be
100 certain but this gives me more
groundedness more certainty when we call
anything certain we can only mean
certain up to a point there is no such
thing as total certainty
and in different areas certainty means
different kinds of things really so I
think I agree entirely with John that
giving up on the idea of certainty is
hugely important and it's the belief
that either science or Reason will lead
us to the same infallible conclusion all
of us
um and will reveal the truth about
things is is
naive dangerous deluded
but not that we should honor science and
reason we should we should also honor
intuition and Imagination and you know
just perhaps to the last thing I shall
say the greatest myth for me is the myth
that is about myth which is the myth of
Orpheus and euridity so Orpheus was a
demigod
and uh he he could with his music Move
Stones he could move people obviously he
could even change the course of a river
so he had some magical power of his
music that nobody could resist and he
got married to a princess eurydice and
after the wedding eurydice with her
bridesmaids was walking in a meadow and
she was Bitten on the heel by a Viper
and she died
an Orpheus was completely
grease struck and he thought I'm going
to go down into the underworld and plead
for her
and something that nobody had ever been
able to succeed at doing or able to go
there at all never mind to succeed so he
went to the underworld and he played for
the gods of the underworld and they were
so moved that they said yes okay we will
give you back your bride on one
condition that you you walk out of the
underworld and you don't look back at
her until you are completely both clear
of the underworld and at the end of his
journey out he couldn't resist taking
a look at his loved one and he was over
overwhelmed he reached towards her and
she shrunk away
back into the underworld never to be
seen again now what that seems to me to
be about is the power of the not looked
at the implicit the thing that has to
remain
outside our diminishing Consciousness
our world of words because it simply is
too great for it and can only be
conveyed through imagination in myths
imagination in
a religious Faith or a spiritual realm
anyway
well thank you all thank you all for
coming out I I think it's apt that you
said this may be the last thing I say
and then talk about how speaking itself
is besmirching whatever you're talking
about yes exactly that's been the
problem
yeah yeah sometimes I have these
intimations when I do this podcast and I
study these different theories I have
these intimations that what I'm doing is
a sin in a sense as a sin is maybe an
incorrect word but it's not progressing
forward it's progressing backward that
by explicating I'm performing and
undoing and I should just stop and
be a monk and go into the monastery and
just not speak because to speak of it
diminishes it one day we must talk about
that yeah yeah we could talk about that
yes right yeah let's talk about not
talking exactly
John any last words and then we wrap
um
I gotta I got very excited at times
because
we've only spoken once before
um
finding a mind as deep
and the heart is deep and sharp
insightful as he had after writing a
truly impressive work uh often
converging and this is in no way trying
to take any credit away from you but
finding it often converging with my work
I find deeply encouraging
um independent lines of research are
valued in science because the chances
that they have been produced by bias
independent lines that converge
the chance that they've been producing
bias is reduced by that very convergence
and the fact that e coming from
something they're very different and we
often found ourselves in very
significant agreement I hope it was
still entertaining for people watching
but for me I just wanted to express the
Gratitude and if I got over enthusiastic
at some points I apologize but I was
I've just I find it deeply encouraging
and I mean that we're very
almost literally very encouraging uh
that's that this kind of convergence has
occurred because for me it raises the
plausibility of my own work and also
helps me of course uh deeply appreciate
the answer but I wanted to thank you
for that because that I mean it I I take
it everything you would we're doing here
was sincere and authentic as as I tried
to be yeah so for me for me it just it
was it's it's powerful I find it a very
powerful experience
a true and I mean I hope this is not
meant in any way off but like a true
peer you know what I mean and playing
with the words we're peering at the same
thing
and and I just I I thank you thank you
very much well I can only respond in
kind uh John I I feel the same thing
it's so rare to find mine so fully in in
sync really
um we found things that we could
slightly gloss for one another but
effectively we're we're really talking
about the same things and I I I have
only gratitude for your kindness and
your warmth and and and the feeling of
you know Fellowship so thank you very
much indeed
I hope we talk again again I hope so too
all right then bye-bye thank you bye-bye
bye bye okay all right thank you thank
you for sticking around for two and a
half hours I appreciate that I hope that
it was enjoyable to you again there's
the website
theoriesofeverything.org that's a place
that you can go to support toe if you're
interested in that like I mentioned in
the intro there are several benefits you
get an ads free audio version you get
that sometimes 12 to 48 hours to a few
days prior to premiering on YouTube you
get discounts to the Live Events when we
finally do have them sometimes those
tickets may even be free so for instance
I'm looking into doing something with
John verakee and Ian mcgilchrist in
person this is all extremely tentative
right now but this is a plan to do in
the future Carl friston in London live
in front of an audience is another
example there will be exclusive merch
and so on there's quite a few benefits
you can text me if you like there's a
number at least we're testing that for
about one week or one month or so again
that's theoriesofeverything.org thank
you all for watching it's great to see
you in the live chat I appreciate all of
the love thank you thank you so much